matt moore will take on the top of this
order here
in the first inning matt moore 6-3 210
pound lefty 32 years of age now
out to short gregorius took him a second
and that gets trey turner to first
if you don't handle it perfectly with
trey turner running he's going to beat
you out
and soto pulls the base hit drake turner
is going to make the turn
and head for third base harper will
throw it on a hop over there
josh one for one with an rbi and a
couple of walks against matt moore
that ball's well hit to right it is
c you later
josh bell just levels off and puts the
nets on top by three
and his rbi total shoots right past
the 50 mark and here's fetty 10th start
career against the phils
28 years old 6'4 200 pounds last start
allowed just one run
unearned so escobar has moved to short
something is going on with trey turner
this is trey at third we've been doing
detective work the whole wedding you
guys are probably happy because i
haven't said a word we've been watching
video over here on the monitor
to see if he's okay he's kind of taking
some deep breaths there i don't know how
great he feels but we'll see
we now get the news that trey turner
tested positive
for covid19 and because of mlb protocols
that's why he was removed from tonight's
game
eugene rolls one back toward the middle
harrison from his backside
can't throw him out harper's two for
four against fetty this year
six for 15 overall with four home runs
live drive out to right center field
soto can't get it it's going to the
scoreboard
sigour read it beautifully he's already
around third heading for home and the
phillies are on the board
rbi double for harper it's a 3-1 ball
game
look at a nice ground ball out there
handled by harrison
so the phillies get a run on the harper
double so gerardo parra finds himself in
the starting
almost the starting lineup now and he
will promptly
line one out to left center some guys
can flat out hit whether they know
they're playing or not
and that's important that gets juan soto
to the plate
soto lifting one to left
see you later
one bounce to the concourse and the nets
have a pair of three-run homers
and both hitters have gone the opposite
way 4-24
109 miles an hour juan soto ladies and
gentlemen he loves to hit
at the bank
and there's some serious paint for you
eric fetty
65th track out of the air in his first
tonight
oh josh harrison yes sir
[Applause]
josh to josh playing up the middle a
little bit
laying out from the knees
and segura already tipping his cap as he
goes across the back i
actually just old school i would throw
my helmet at josh harrison but i would
definitely not say hey thank you for
robbing me of a hit
that was really cool two and two
ground ball to first reese has it goes
to second for one back to first
in time
who's the other way slicing away from
soto that's a fair ball and it's going
to scoot to the corner
and hoskins will get to second base and
he's there standing
line drive out to right field soto going
back it's going to be off the scoreboard
hoskins will score
herrera the second the throw and he is
in their standing
rbi double with six to two
look at that deflection that ball might
have been in center field
eric fetty takes one right off the boot
and he kicks it over to bell for a 1-3
two balls two strikes to bell popped up
third base side toreyas is there on the
slide what a play yeah we keep talking
about him how good he's been for this
team
no matter where he's playing third short
wherever
young man knows what to do with that
leather in his hand
out to center field roblaise heading
back toward the state farm side
he jumps it's off the top of it harper
can run he's around
second the ball picked up in center
field they're gonna wave them home
the throw by soto is not
in time inside the park home run
it's a 6-3 ball game
yeah he's sniffing it right there tommy
took that peek back and he saw where
everyone was and dusty was
giving him the goal give bryce credit
man he was going all the way and this
could electrify this
just not only this crowd but this
offense
and a high fly ball to left field parr
is going back toward the wall
it is gone back
to back home runs one in the yard the
other one
out of the yard it's a 6-4 game
[Applause]
check swing roller to third to reyes to
second for one over to first in time
i gotta say john i am shocked that they
were able to turn a double play
seemingly that easy
little flare single
see swinging a miss and a foul tip on a
ball
that was boring in on him two balls two
strikes
swag and a miss he got him at 100 miles
an hour
escobar sliding after a good running
attempt at it
and he catches that foul tip and wonder
suero mows down the
phillies in the bottom of the seventh
inning
ground ball to third it's a fair ball
thereas behind the bag across the
diamond dug out by hoskins
and the side is retired the 3-2 pitch
up high ball four battled back to get a
second walk of the night wow
the tying run is coming to the plate
three balls one strike to herrera
and ball four flap of the hands from
herrera
as andrew knapp is coming up go to
to left
para just enough room all right
everybody take a deep breath oh my
goodness
tonight it's six to four and brad hand
gets the same hitters to face
as 24 hours ago ground ball
over to third key boom's got it flips to
first he pulled bell off the bag
he pulls him way off the bag and segora
goes to
second the tying run is coming up to the
plate
back door in the breaking ball and rio
muto didn't get it para has it won out
[Applause]
there we go and he pops him up on a
slider
trace pereira two down
102nd tying run at the plate
start three call game over
the life of a closer ice water in his
veins
and brett hand has his 21st save